mark when we look at where the LA
Clippers traded for I mean it changed
the face of the valuation of teams if
you think about what you paid 15 years
ago and where you value your team at now
what is it 1.15 billion though they're
not for sale I mean I think it's worth a
lot more than that maybe Tim Cook will
buy it I don't know but basketball has
become a foundation tenet for a lot more
than just television so for the Clippers
they're a tenant at Staples so they'll
be able to have the opportunity at some
point to go out and build their own
arena to build whatever they want to
build around that go out and get a TV
deal so basketball has gone from just
being a franchise to an NBA team being a
tentpole
and that's what's raised evaluation when
you bought your team was it a passion
project or real investment because no in
hindsight maybe that's an investment
yeah I know it was not an investment at
all I wanted as a long time suffering
Dallas Mavericks family I mean we were
voted the worst professional sports
franchise of the 90s I just wanted a
winning team and there was the opening
night of 99 2000 season we were
undefeated it was opening night and it
wasn't a sellout there was no energy in
the building I can do a better job than
this boom that's when it happened it's
weird to have two teams on the market we
have the Hulk's right now a lot of
interest here a lot of people that were
looking in LA Dodgers and Clippers are
also looking there but Brooklyn hmm
different situations but people I talked
to the sports banking community tell me
that LA is a better situation what we
want you I don't know I don't know
enough about the Nets situation I even
know if they're for sale right I don't
play that close that's another one of
the problems by the way they don't know
what's happened but you know look NBA
franchises are going to be in demand for
the reason I just mentioned right there
a tentpole for an entertainment
environment they're a tentpole for real
estate there's so much value now accrue
to the NBA and it's probably you know if
you look at the other main franchises
main sports we're probably growing the
fastest in terms of interest and so I
think that's a big plus versus with the
scalable opportunity of international
right and that's right technology comes
in limiting across the board right so
yeah it's great point in that for the
NBA it's not just about your local
market it's about being part of an
organization earning owning one
thirtieth of an organization that's
expanding globally into places other
sports other than maybe
Kocher can go well that's not about
managing a winning team you're here
specifically today talking about data
and analytics do you feel like teams and
management have become too reliant on
data mining no I mean it's very much um
an alumn analysis yeah analogous to the
stock market um in that there was a
point in time 10 years ago 15 years ago
where you know if you understood a
company you could trade as an individual
you saw a lot of day traders now we've
seen companies and so much money come
into the market that's become much more
efficient and it's hard to get a data
edge the same thing has happened in
professional sports and in basketball
specifically where when we started using
analytics 15 years ago we were one of
the only teams and it gave us a big
advantage five you know 2005-2006 where
one of maybe three or four
we still had a huge advantage now in
2015
every NBA team uses analytics to a great
extent and so your advantage traditional
analytics your advantage is pretty much
gone it's efficient market you have to
find new things that's appoints rebounds
and blocks analytics you know how
advanced in advance it okay but let's
take it further you pay your doctor has
a longer term contract than any of your
players every day Yeah right
you're looking at you're looking at
health and mental analytics yeah you're
few psychologist is going to like you
you're you are head on that year where
we're trying to write so I'm investing
in new things right so in terms of
health analytics right um I've vested a
company called catapult Sports that
monitors our heart rate and a lot of
other things and sends it wirelessly so
we can capture it I've invested in a
company called free D fre IDI that takes
sports view video to the next next level
where rather than just taking cameras
and capturing video and looking for
motion in it it goes the exact opposite
it takes cameras captures video and
turns the whole thing into data so that
you can then take almost like an oculus
rift type view and look to say okay
so Dirk is looking this way why didn't
he see this guy and you can actually
recreate exactly what he was seen so
that you can take analytics to the next
level company called axon which trains
you to do certain things there's so many
new places in an efficient market that's
what you have to do you have to find new
sources of information is there an
argument to be made though that you're
taking away sort of the spirit in the
heart of the game oh no no it's look I'm
not sitting down sitting no
don't practice your free-throws right
that that's not it at all this is just
me as the minder yeah yeah I've got to
win right I want to have the best
franchise possible I want to put the
best team on the court and you can't
just make those analysis and make those
decisions in a vacuum any more than you
would flip a coin to decide what stocks
or what indexes you were going to invest
in you know and there's you know there's
the old random walk down Wall Street
that says once the market is efficient
right then you don't have an edge you
just give your money to the least
expensive index fund that's what's
happening with traditional advanced
analytics today it's almost a random
walk through the basketball court and so
the only way to combat that in my
opinion is to go out there and find new
sources of data and find new ways to
compete and that's what I try to focus
its it with tech as well it seems to me
I'm going to talk to an owner it's what
are you doing to bring the crowd make a
compelling event well I have Wi-Fi and
broadband in my head for that there's no
answer two different things right so
trying to build a team trying to win
games that's in this bucket
trying to create the best fan experience
that's a completely different bucket you
know I don't want people using Wi-Fi at
our games I don't want that's called
look now when you're looking I want you
know what makes going to a game unique
versus sitting on the couch is the
energy you feel when you walk into the
case study is the Duke University
student section everybody up jumping for
two hours yeah they're not they're not
they're the target audience for this but
I'm not doing they're not doing it right
because getting away from your device
and going getting out of the house and
doing something unique when you walk
into a Mavs game I want you to feel the
energy right I don't want you to even
think about your phone I want you to oh
shoot I forgot to check on the
babysitter right oh shoot I forgot to
check my email you know we spend more
probably as much as all the other teams
and all professional sports combined to
do original videos that we put up on the
jumbotron we upgraded our big screen in
the middle of the arena to at the time
it was the largest indoor screen
anywhere in the world just so we could
do better entertainment do you want to
see your players wearing GoPros because
it would no that's ridiculous what the
dumbest not anybody get to sit on the
floor you could have that experience you
know what that means that means that
you're not creating enough value for the
people at the top of the arena right so
it's not about making them feel like
they're missing something - let me
recreate what I don't have it's one on
pain so we have $10 seats and we used to
have $2 seats but we stopped them
because they all got scalped right but
$10 states I want you to go in there
feeling I can feel the energy I can
the game I can remember the thing about
going to a sporting event with his high
school college whatever there's no place
else where you're gonna somebody makes a
shot to win a game you're gonna stand up
and hi-fi and hug and kiss the person
next to you you never met them before in
your entire life you're going to scream
defense you're going to yell all these
things you don't do that in front of a
TV at home and anything you do that
prevents you from clapping screaming
yelling or stomping it's a mistake
about convenience though I mean let's
talk about technology can do concession
lines bathroom weight I mean these are
things where it's invisible in the arena
no question and so one of my companies
motional off is the sensors company and
all that does is count what's in front
of it in real time so that I can know
that here's the line to get in I've got
to do something to improve the line
here's the line at the concession stand
whatever it may be here's the traffic
flows and so I have to adapt to do that
and so it's not just about here's a
better way to order something it's about
understanding the flow and using
analytics really to understand how your
customers interact with you our product
the American Airlines Center as a team
owner does all start weekend to the game
mean anything nope I could have answered
that one but it's fun for the fans
you know this there's two elements to
all-star week and one is the corporate
side where it's a chance for the NBA to
really engage with our sponsors and have
parties have fun it's you know it's a
great party weekend um and then from a
fan's perspective it's great for kids
right when you go to the all-star game
the most rewarding thing to see isn't a
jump shot from dirt isn't something from
LeBron or Kevin Durant or whoever
if the smiles on the kids faces because
they all have different jerseys from
different teams they've come in from out
of town they're they're screaming and
yelling and they're becoming fans of the
game so it's I look at it more as a
training module and then on television
is fun to watch too because you can get
into it and just watch the fun of it has
it helped basketball that these athletes
have become huge brands huge
personalities style star absolutely
particularly for the NBA you don't see
that in other sports I mean other than
the you know Dallas Cowboys you know one
of the most visible teams highest TV
ratings you know who Tony Romo is and
you could name another player maybe
Jason Wynn you couldn't have anybody
else on the NBA you know locally you can
name all 15 players and across the top
25 50 100 players in the NBA
you probably know them by sight and
you'll know them by social media and
you'll be able to interact so special
about basketball that those players will
be we're able to create such brand
identity there you can see their faces
first of all right
the way you play the game create some
personality you don't really get that as
much in football alignment just you know
making a great block you know it doesn't
show personality in a lot of respects
and flair yeah it's just there's no
personality people don't have identities
in other sports nearly the way they do
in the NBA because the NBA game is
continuous unlike others and so you're
watching dirt Kevin Durant Monta Ellis
you know Tyson Chandler and you get to
see who they are how they react to
things and you don't see that and then a
lot of that is replayed in social media
whether it's Instagram on Twitter now
cyberdust my app or Facebook even what
staggered us cyberdust is a response to
Twitter right right now on Twitter when
you get followers and you post something
you're very very concerned about trolls
and you have to coach whatever you say
and anticipate how somebody might
respond that's a problem and it's really
tamp down how people communicate online
with cyberdust you download the app
cyberdust it's on App Store all the app
stores right you can communicate
one-on-one but what makes it unique is
when you send a message or you post
something 30 seconds after it's read it
disappears forever and it's secure it's
not like snapchat it's not getting
hacked it's just gone the NSA can't go
back and get a message it's gone so what
happens as a result if I have 350,000
followers we have like 2 million users
right now yeah absolutely
um but what happens is if I post
something it's not out there for
everybody to see it once and if a troll
comes in and responds I'm the only one
who sees it so it's troll free posting
like a Twitter like a reddit would be
and that's just led to a lot of growth
any message for Tim Cook about
screengrab you know I'd like to see a
lot of screen grabs stopped but you know
what people talk about screen grabs in
terms of privacy it's nothing the bigger
thing for Tim Cook the new new version
of Yosemite with QuickTime you can
attach any iPhone and record anything
except on cyberdust we figured out how
to stop it but all these other privacy
apps
whether it's snapchat whether it's
wicker whatever it is you can just
record all the conversations so
screenshots aren't really an issue
because you're only getting one screen
and you may not know who it's from but
the ability of Yosemite and QuickTime
movies to record anything privacy is
done no matter no matter what encrypted
video doesn't matter because you can
just capture it both sides on QuickTime
video Oh Tim Cook I hope you're watching
cyberdust it's coming after you